solve for Z 5z plus seven is less than
27 or negative 3z is less than or equal
to 18 so this is a compound inequality
we have two we have two conditions here
so Z can satisfy this or Z can satisfy
this over here so let's just solve each
of these inequalities and just know that
Z can satisfy either of them so let's
just look at this so if we look at just
this one over here we have 5z plus 7 is
less than 27 let's isolate the Z's on
the left-hand side so let's subtract 7
from both sides to get rid of this 7 on
the left-hand side
and so our left-hand side is just going
to be 5z plus 7 minus 7 those cancel out
5z is less than 27 minus 20 sorry 27
minus 7 is 20 so we 5z is less than 20
now we can divide both sides of this
inequality by 5 and we don't have to
swap the inequality because we're
dividing by a positive number and so we
get Z is less than 20 over 5 Z is less
than 4 now this was only one of the
conditional script the other one over
here we have negative 3z is less than or
equal to 18 now to isolate the Z we
could just divide both sides of this
inequality by negative 3 but remember
when you divide both or multiply both
sides of an inequality by a negative
number you have to swap the inequality
so this is so we could write this
negative 3z we're going to divide it by
negative 3 and then you have 18 we're
going to divide it by negative 3 but
we're going to swap the inequality so
the less Center equal will become
greater than or equal to and so these
guys cancel out negative 3 divided by
negative 3 is 1 so we have Z is greater
than or equal to 18 over negative 3 is
negative 6
and remember it's this constraint or
this constraint and this constraint
right over here boils down to this and
this one boils down to this so our
solution set Z is less than 4 or Z is
greater than or equal to negative 6
so let me make this clear let me rewrite
it so Z could be less than 4 or Z is
greater than or equal to negative 6 it
can satisfy either one of these and this
is kind of this is kind of interesting
here because let's let's plot these well
let's plot these so there's a number
line right over there let's say that 0
is over here we have 1 2 3 4 is right
over there and then negative 6 we have 1
2 3 4 5 6 that's negative 6 over there
now let's think about Z being less than
4 z be Z being less than 4 we would put
a circle around 4 since we're not
including 4 and it would be everything
everything less than 4 everything less
than 4 now let's think about what Z
being greater than or equal to negative
6 would mean that means you can include
negative 6 and it's everything let me do
that a different color it means you can
include negative 6 I want to do that
here we go it means you include negative
6 we do even a more different color do
it in orange so Z is greater than or
equal to negative 6 means you can
include negative 6 and it's everything
greater than that greater than that
including 4 so it's everything greater
than that so what we see as we've
essentially shaded in the entire number
line every number will meet either one
of these constraints or both of them if
we're over here we're going to meet both
of the constraints if we're one of these
number a number out here we're going to
meet this constraint if we're a number
down here we're going to meet this
constraint you can just try it out with
a bunch of numbers 0 will work 0 plus 0
plus 7 is 7 which is less than 27 and 3
times 0 is less than 18 so it meets both
constraints if we put 4 here it should
only meet one of the constraints
negative 3 times 4 is negative 12 which
is less than 18 so it meets this
constraint but it won't meet this
constraint because you do 5 times 4 plus
7 is 27 which is not less than 27 it's
equal to 27 but remember this is an or
so you just have to meet one of the
constraints so 4 meets this constraint
so even four works so it's really the
entire number line
will satisfy either one or both of these
constraints